one two three four five six seven eight  nine ten  huh okay all right let's go I was less  susceptible to scares now that I am  earlier the sentence does make sense  yeah [ __ ] you too I don't know what I'm  doing  [ __ ] you me yeah yeah I get quit I that  way yeah I get asked this question all  the time you know everyone wants to know  what my favorite game was uh I forgot I  cleaned everything wanting to that's  really funny baboo baboo baboo okay  no-oh-oh just do this no Alec  we stop it no no no no sling  now I'm sweaty that was the idea let's  get dressed great I'll be able to top my  head  that [ __ ] fridge needs to shut the  [ __ ] off  so sure ha  so have you ever met a fan and slept  with their entire family and murdered  their entire family a via [ __ ] don't  you admit it you here for me for ma so  you with man was that um and thank you  all these and all other configuration to  be I'm Wilbur Wharf I yes time series  oh very Andrew